lucie quinson merci d'avoir accepté de
répondre à nos questions alors on le
sait avec la crise sanitaire notamment à
l'industrie du pétrole est en grande
difficulté alors pourquoi les banques
pensent qu urgent de sauver ce secteur
est ce que c'est un secteur qui est
encore indispensable aujourd'hui
alors le secteur du gaz de schiste est
un des secteurs les plus risquées
aujourd'hui à la fois sur le plan
climatique que sanitaire le gaz de
schiste pour rappel est un intime
pratique interdite en france pour en
raison de ses impacts sur
l'environnement sur la pollution des
sols et la santé des populations
malheureusement aujourd'hui il est en
fort développement aux états unis
notamment grâce au financement et
investissement des du secteur financier
international donc ces partis dont fait
partie la france
il est encore trop tôt pour savoir ce
qu'il sera fait et les décisions qui
seront prises par les acteurs financiers
dans les prochains mois nous les
appelons forcément à mettre un terme à
leur soutien à l'intégralité du secteur
et de rediriger leurs financements et
investissements vers les énergies
renouvelables
justement lucile pinsson dans une époque
où la conscience du réchauffement
climatique est grandissante on se
souvient de l'accord de paris comment
comprenez vous des banques françaises ne
privilégie pas pleinement aujourd'hui
les énergies renouvelables alors c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'explique pas
surtout lorsqu'on regarde en effet la
rentabilité du secteur du secteur du gaz
de schiste puisque c'est un secteur qui
vit sous perfusion monétaire depuis
depuis plusieurs années avec énormément
d'entreprises qui font qu'ils font
faillite
et pourtant on voit que les banques
françaises ont fourni 24 milliards de
dollars de financement à ce secteur
depuis 2016 avec notamment en effet
société générale qui est la première
banque française à financer le secteur
avec à elle seule 11 milliards en sa
direction
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il ya des
annonces qui sont faites hier à la
sortie du rapport crédit agricole a
réagi en annonçant qu'il ne financerait
plus d'ici 2022
les entreprises spécialisées dans le
secteur est là peut-être qu'on a un
point de réponse à vous
question puisque crédit agricole s'est
engagé à n'exclure que les entreprises
spécialisées dans la production de gaz
et pétrole de schiste à savoir les
entreprises forcément les plus risquée
financièrement et celles qui sont déjà
aujourd'hui sur le bord de la faillite
on pense notamment une entreprise six
pay qui a été fortement soutenu ces
dernières années par crédit agricole
ce que ne dit pas à crédit agricole et
ce sur quoi ils s'engagent pas c'est
tout le reste de l'industrie du secteur
du pétrole et du gaz de schiste
or extraction à savoir les volets des
papes nine de transport ou encore les
terminaux d'exportation de gaz naturel
liquéfié qui permettent aux industriels
de trouver des débouchés sur les marchés
internationaux pour vendre leur
production et surtout un des gros points
manquants du crédit agricole c'est bien
entendu les majors pétrolières et
gazières qui ne sont pas du tout
concerné par ces annonces pourquoi ces
entreprises là sont très diversifiés et
donc les risques liés à leur activité
dans les gaz et pétrole de schiste sont
diluées et donc sont moins de facto le
crédit agricole à moins de risque de
financer ces entreprises on parle là des
grosses majors pétrolières et gazières
comme shell comme exxon ou comme chez
brawn cependant ce qui n'est pas risquée
financièrement du couple pour les
acteurs financiers les pour le climat
puisqu'on parle aussi des entreprises
qui sont à l'avant garde de l'expansion
du secteur du pétrole et du gaz de
schiste aux états unis aujourd'hui 85%
de l'expansion des énergies fossiles est
prévu en amérique du nord et repose
notamment sur ces bassins du pétrole et
du gaz de schiste américain il faut
absolument empêcher cette bombe
climatique d'exposer et donc d'exclure
toute entreprise qui a des plans de
développement dans le secteur mais en
continuant de financer sans condition
les majors pétrolières et gazières les
banques et les investisseurs français
rate le tir et continue d'être
d'aggraver la situation sur le plan
climatique et sanitaire du coup
aujourd'hui lui
si pinson ce que vous demandez aux
acteurs financiers finalement cessé de
s'investir d'être proactifs dans le
développement des économies vertes mais
est ce qu'il s'y retrouverait alors les
économies les énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui sont beaucoup plus rentable
que de nombreux secteurs des énergies
fossiles
il ya énormément de rapport qui démontre
que les fonds d'investissement qui ont
fait le pari de rester investi dans les
énergies fossiles ont en réalité perdu
énormément d'argent
de par ce choix au niveau du sarment sur
lesquels les acteurs financiers sont
toujours toujours appelé dans lequel
sont les acteurs financiers français
sont toujours impliqués
on sait aujourd'hui désormais que
construire des nouvelles capacités de
production d'électricité renouvelable
coûte moins cher que maintenir en
opération les centrales à charbon
existante
merci beaucoup lui si mince en avoir
partagé votre analyse rappelle que vous
êtes fondatrice et directrice générale
de l'ol gérait klein finances